[Applaudissements]
merci madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Ministre de l'économie ça y est vous
avez eu la lourde charge d'annoncer au
20H la première grande mesure du
gouvernement de Gabriel hatal vous qui
nous promettiez solennellement qu'il n'y
aurait pas de rattrapage des prix
pourtant une nouvelle hausse de 10 %
sera bien appliqué au tarif de
l'électricité le 1er février 2024 la 4e
hausse depuis la réélection d'Emmanuel
Macron plus 45 % en 2 ans du jamais vu
en moyen ce sera plus 18 € par mois pour
une famille qui se chauffe à
l'électricité plus 116 € par mois pour
nos boulangers déjà asphyxiés et combien
de milliers d'euros ajoutés à la
détresse de nos agriculteurs les
Français sont condamnés à rembourser
l'argent que vous avez distribuer
pendant les élections alors que 30 %
d'entre eux ont froid chez eux ou
renoncent à se chauffer correctement par
manque d'argent cela monte même à 50 %
chez les Français vivants dans nos
campagnes vous devriez avoir honte de
ces résultats après pres 7 ans au
pouvoir malgré toutes vos excuses et
tous vos mensonges ces ha sont bien le
fruit de choix énergétique ératique de
votre gouvernement et de votre choix de
rétablir une taxe alors que le prix de
l'électricité baisse sur les marchés le
RN réitère ses propositions baisse de la
TVA de 20 à 55 sur toutes les énergies
libérer la France des règles absurdes du
marché européen de l'électricité
investir massivement dans la recherche
et le nucléaire énergie la moins chère
et la moins polluante monsieur le
ministre la première décision du nouveau
gouvernement a donc été d'affaiblir un
peu plus le pouvoir d'achat des Français
jusqu'à quel sommet Attal le taxeur et
le maire le menteur vont-ils continuer à
faire exploser les factures des
Français la parole est à Monsieur Bruno
Le Maire ministre de l'Économie des
Finances de la souveraineté industrielle
et
numérique madame la Présidente Monsieur
le Député
peffer vous êtes un peu pingre
avec les Français votre proposition de
baisse sur la TVA sur l'électricité de
20 5,5 % ça représente une économie de
l'ordre de 300 € par an pour les ménages
là où nous nous avons pris en charge la
moitié de la facture jusqu'à 1000 € pour
les ménages par
an nous avons fait trois fois mieux nous
sommes trois fois plus généreux que vous
pour défendre le pouvoir d'achat des
Français
vous nous parlez de
nucléaire vous nous parlez de population
précaire vous nous parlez d'énergie
renouvelable mais qu'est-ce qui va
financer les énergies renouvelables le
nucléaire et la protection des plus
précaires sinon la taxe intérieure c'est
la consommation finale d'électricité qui
est là pour financer l'avenir de
l'électricité française la souveraineté
et l'indépendance de la nation en
matière de production électrique je
croyais que le rassemblement national
était attaché à l'indépendance à la
souveraineté française je m'aperçois que
ce n'est n'est pas le cas mais dans le
fond cet exemple la taxe intérieure sur
la consommation finale d'électricité
elle montre assez bien
l'irresponsabilité totale du
rassemblement national et elle montre
assez bien ce que vous êtes comme
formation
politique vous n'avez aucune solution
pour le passé vous n'avez que des
critiques pour le présent et vous n'avez
aucune proposition pour l'avenir voilà
qui résume bien le rassemblement
national je vous remerci monsieur le
ministre monsieur le
député monsieur le ministre avec vous ce
qui est bien c'est que c'est toujours la
faute des autres jamais de la vôtre qui
a abandonné nos centrales nucléaires et
hydrauliques face aux pressions des
écologistes et de l'Union européenne
c'est vous qui a fermé FIM c'est vous
qui a subventionner les éoliennes nous
rendant dépendant au gaz russes de
Monsieur Poutine c'est vous alors vous
faites les mauvais choix demain nous
ferons les bons et les Français nous
font confiance merci beaucoup monsieur
le
ministre
qui a dit monsieur le député que
l'énergie nucléaire était extrêmement
dangereuse et qu'il fallait en sortir
Marine Le Pen la présidente du
rassemblement
national